how exactly did you persuade molex to
give you their blessing wouldn't they
rather build the digital walnuts
themselves the process of persuading
Bullock's international to partner with
us on this project was a very
challenging one it took me many months
and I I just really believe that this
was a good partnership and and had to
convince them they they had been
approached by other companies that
wanted to make cameras using their name
and they had declined those offers and
it was a
long process as I said but I believe
ultimately they signed on because they
believe in the product they believe that
we are going to be making a long-lasting
high quality camera that will service
the market that they wants so strongly
dominated and I think that that they
would like their name and the product
those sort of the morality of their
products to live on so if someone was in
a similar position whatever the product
how much is too much in terms of polite
persistence how often would you say
follow up with a bigger organization so
that you're not annoying what you're
still getting your message across and I
think one important thing is to figure
out who it is you need to
are now talking to someone at the very
top but at the beginning it was more
difficult for Joe to to get to that
point and I think
early on
I yeah I think I called someone at the
company or related company probably once
or twice a week for nine months before I
really got to where we wanted to be
yeah it wasn't like that they were not
interested it was that it just took a
while to get to the person that would be
the appropriate person to talk to you
know some people paint us back to the
distributing arm and they were like what
we wouldn't be the people that would be
appropriate for this so if there were
someone else wanting to make this kind
of partnership with a company I think
doing the research to figure out who
they should be talking to and you know
what if any history they have with
partnering with other companies would be
good so what kept you going to continue
with a phone call email whatever it was
for week how could you do just finally
give up and say well obviously this is
Joe is a very persistent person
so it's not surprising that after months
not getting quite there you know that
that wouldn't stop and you know if you
he was ever told no and I think that
was an important thing but also just you
know persevering and pushing through I
think a lot of not just a business world
but the world in general was is being
able to be persistent in the face of
hardship sort of or something like that
I just really wanted it and decided I
was going to do whatever it took to get
there and in terms of the length of any
email or phone call which he keep it
brief or would you go into more detail
now I mean some sometimes now in order
to call Switzerland I was generally
waking up at three or four in the
morning so and sometimes it was an hour
to hour long conversation in at four in
the morning in order to get to a place
of understanding but you know at the end
of the day they would never have said
yes if they were not interested by the
product if they were not convinced
we were the right people not just that
we were the right people but that we are
capable of delivering because you know
in touching themselves to this you know
they are lending their name
listed for and that's awesome because
it's great when you're starting out on a
project to have like
it's a really big deal for us
you